pour changer un peu les idées beaubourg
fais avec nous une visite à beaubourg
décrié et beaubourg admirer puisque près
de sept cent mille français ont visité
le centre pompidou depuis son ouverture
il ya moins d'un mois et demi 10 à 15000
personnes vont chaque jour à beaubourg
parce que beaubourg qu'on aime ou qu'on
n'aime pas est devenu comme la tour
eiffel une des grandes curiosités
nationale beaubourg pour toucher
beaubourg pour sentir beau bourg
peut-être pouvoir beaubourg et sourire
comme l'a fait notre reporter christian
héraud
ma
et été
eli lilly
ah ah
et c'est le thé les airs au dessus au
niveau 63 50 face à l'escaladé remonte
en quatrième cinquième répondait
c'est un petit vêtement de l'iguane
chercheurs
c'est
ça
à
e
oui